have you guys ever get on each other's
nerves we've been together three years
now oh you know we've been together for
almost three years I'm scared okay here
we go number one what are you going to
choose what a Sophie's Choice you have a
bigger board is it a list
I just left two things I just put down
one oh wait I've got another one I mean
you have a lot to get through
I'll go first I'll guess what yours are
for me just general OCD you're not far
off yeah
my pet peeve is that you have so many
pet peas one thing that definitely
thought I do is I tend to interrupt when
we're telling stories or when we're
hanging out with friends that's true but
that's not what I've written down it's
the point where I'm like okay I've tried
to do everything right and then I did
like one more thing wrong and I'm like
stop telling me I did things wrong right
on what did she eat it's on the great
job on something last night I told you
that you did a good job picking out that
fruit picking out broccoli yes oh no
nany is driving and her washing dishes
the way I wash dishes yeah because he
washed them but you don't clean them
they are clean can i vlog about this
address and like send footage too we
have talked about the fact recently that
I don't love children
number one hates baby slash kids she
doesn't care for them at all some of
them are cute I'm not saying I hate all
children I'm what like a crazy person
did you write that I don't know how to
make a bed nope that I don't always lock
the door and I am good on that oh that I
don't wash the dishes good enough ding
ding ding day
yeah can't fully clean a dish I've
gotten this criticism and so I have from
other people no from you I don't go
walking around watching other girls
dishes better not but I dance a lot I
was gonna press that but I thought you'd
get in faulted so I didn't put it God he
leaves his tissues everywhere because
for some reason that constantly has a
snotty nose
check this out at least it's not dirty
well I'm not a weird okay I mean I feel
like everything's mostly around me
cleaning like not cleaning the cat's
litter box not doing the dishes so I did
write down that she doesn't do dishes
with a angry face and lazy cleaner and
then I said you criticize my driving
which we talked about earlier I
definitely did not anticipate how lazy
you are number one and it's underlined
socks why are they everywhere Oh
why are you we found a sock in the bed
last night what your house shoes are
like all of don't talk exactly how she's
on camera I thought I'd be worse at this
guessing the new because I tell you when
I'm annoyed usually I don't pay
attention oh that's not one either but
it should have been I did it I nailed it
I didn't do well no you didn't I've
learned that we're both pretty good at
compromising and listening to each other
everybody realize that we shouldn't
force stuff on each other yes we do talk
to a therapist about how we communicate
and I think that it is so important and
I think that everybody should like
really think about how they're talking
to their partner yeah at the end of the
day you make a really good team so it's
just kind of reiterate
[Music]
[Music]
you